hey guys it is Thursday much the 31st
today my name is Jess and hear some
gaming news Xbox bottle Spencer has said
that halo 5 is unlikely to make its way
to PC after recent Microsoft build 2016
conference he explained halo 5 was
shipped at a console game if we're going
to bring halo to the PC moving forward
and we're going to plan on both
platforms I don't want to get into the
world where we're looking back it
doesn't mean there's nothing in halo 5
that could ever end up on pc but I'd
much rather look forward with what our
plans are Spencer added that the
publisher intends to bring xbox one
games to Pacey and vice versa but that
this will depend on a game suitability
for certain platforms microsoft recently
confirmed that all future fought the
games will come to both xbox and pc the
division developer massive entertainment
have detailed the massive patch that
players can expect to land next month
the update includes the game's first
incursion mission which is the divisions
take on MMO raids it's a challenging
encounter you'll need to fight all the
way through in one go no checkpoints
merch making is available for this mode
but if your team dies you'll have to
start over also on the way are several
new greentech gear sets and by equipping
matching gear sets you'll be able to
unlock specific talents the sets are
called centuries call strikers battle
gear technicians Authority and path of
the nomads which are focused on
different play styles you can get a
bunch of the new gear as well as a
special weekly reward for completing the
Falcon lost incursion mission but one
gift that can only be earned through the
dark side you'll also now be able to
trade items well you can drop the item
on the ground and someone else can pick
it up much like diablo 3 there will be a
timer on this action and you'll need to
be worried that anyone else in your
group can pick up the item once you've
dropped it other new additions include a
spectator camera new assignments as well
as supply drops in the dark zone which
will reward you with gear that does not
leave
being extracted the incursion update
launches for free on April twelfth
finally halo 5 may not be making its way
to the pace a but Final Fantasy 15
lightly game director Hajime Tabata told
Engadget that they are aware of the big
call for a pc version unfortunately we
weren't able to do simultaneous
development on a PC and console version
15 he explained that Square Enix's plan
was to maximize and optimize everything
about this date for consoles which left
no time for a pc edition although he did
add we will definitely take a good hard
look at pc and what we need to do and
consider all our options currently Final
Fantasy 33 to 14 are available to play
on PC so chances are hopefully pretty
good let me know down in that comment
section if you want Final Fantasy 15 to
come to PC you can also head to gamespot
we've got stories on hitman episode 2
and new halo 5 DLC map that is
everything I happy you today but you
join me same time tomorrow for the best
stories up the entire week and we'll
catch you then